lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comparar estas dos cantidades 0.17 y 0.2
quiero saber cuál de estas cantidades es
más grande o si quizás son iguales los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta una forma
de resolver esto es tratar de visualizar
lo pueden ver a cada uno de estos
cuadrados como un entero el de la
izquierda está dividido en 100 secciones
iguales tenemos 10 renglones y cada
renglón tiene 10 cuadritos así que hay
si en cuadritos cada cuadrito representa
una centésima parte del entero
este número 0.17 podemos verlo como 17
centésimas vamos a colorear las una
centésima dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez centésimas noten
que con diez centésimas color es todo un
reglón lo que es lo mismo que una décima
seguimos con once centésimas
13 14 15 16 y 17 una forma de visualizar
0.17 que son 17 centésimas es la
fracción de este entero que está
iluminada en magenta y qué hay del 0.2
esto es lo mismo que dos décimas por lo
que tomamos nuestro entero y lo
dividimos en diez partes iguales como lo
hicimos aquí y noten que cada sección o
renglón es igual a diez centésimas
iluminemos dos décimas en una décima y
otra décima
cuál de estas cantidades es mayor pues
vemos que hemos iluminado más de el
segundo entero el de dos décimas en
comparación con el de diecisiete
centésimas esto tiene sentido porque el
dos décimas es lo mismo que veinte
centésimas y veinte centésimas es mayor
que diecisiete centésimas para llegar a
las veinte centésimas nos faltaría
llenar estos tres cuadritos para
colorear y así tener la misma fracción
que en este otro entero así que cuál es
mayor pues dos décimas como lo
escribimos nuestra desigualdad va a
abrirse hacia el número más grande
tenemos que 0.17 o diecisiete centésimas
es menor que dos décimas otra forma de
la que pudimos resolver esto sin tener
que dibujar todo esto es fijarnos en el
lugar o posición de mayor valor por
ejemplo en el lugar de las unidades
tenemos cero en ambas cantidades
pasamos a la siguiente posición de mayor
valor el de las décimas y aquí tenemos
una décima y acá tenemos dos décimas y
simplemente con esto sin necesidad de
ver el valor que hay en las otras
posiciones notamos que tenemos más
décimas aquí que acá lo que nos dice que
esta será la más grande la regla general
es ubicar la cantidad que hay en la
posición de mayor valor y si uno de los
números tiene un dígito más grande en
esta posición de mayor valor pues
entonces esta cantidad será la más
grande si son iguales entonces
comparamos lo que hay en la siguiente
posición de más valor y así
sucesivamente y otra manera de
resolverlo es visualizarlo como lo vimos
aquí